how are you doing today sir good steve
nice to meet you man nice to meet you
i'm imagining you are
where are you
i'm actually in florida of all places oh
intro i thought for some reason i
thought it was europe or something
because it was dark but then i wrote
behind you but i realized it's just a
bookcase oh yeah
yeah that's where that's where the
starling is going to go the words
okay exactly yeah
um so um how long since saint vincent
had you and melissa and even chris
talked about working together again
oh well i i'm listening i've been
talking about working together since
saint vincent so
we talk about it all the time we've
actually danced around a few different
projects over the years um trying to
find something to do
uh
so all the time is the short answer like
all the time trying to find something
and when this came up um i immediately
thought of her and actually chris
was there what was the closest project
that came
to being made before this one with
melissa
melissa
has a television series with her husband
ben falcone coming out on netflix called
god's favorite idiot
and i was going to go and do that
with them and join their team and then
um you know co-written travel and just
kind of they shot that in australia and
it just kind of didn't work out
um one of the things that's interesting
is that the original blacklist script
for this project the roles were gender
switched and i think it's so much better
with what you did with it
having melissa play the strong one and
you know chris playing the one who is
struggling can you sort of talk about
that aspect
well when i first read the script that's
how it was it was the man holding down
the fort stronger and the female
perceived perceivably weaker taking a
mental time out and it just didn't feel
it felt cliche to me i'm like we've seen
that you know five thousand times
haven't we seen that five thousand times
haven't we lived that like uh our whole
lives thinking that's the truth
and for me it just wasn't accurate it
wasn't the truth it wasn't modern it
wasn't fresh
it wasn't just it just really wasn't
realistic i mean i i come from
a single mom and i've been married 25
years and
my two daughters it's like
they're so much stronger than i am all
the time and so much better and
healthier and all those things
and so flipping it was like just a like
a natural thing it was like the minute
we flipped it we're like yeah of course
that's it of course that's it
of course the woman is holding up um the
world because women are holding up the
world currently so it just made a lot of
sense
uh what was it about the script because
i would listen i would imagine you read
a lot of scripts you work on a lot of
scripts obviously you are a very
talented writer um what was it about
this story that said i need to make this
uh i think it was really the story the
hopefulness of the story it was the
hopefulness of a couple
struggling through and pushing through a
tragedy and getting to the other side
i'm always interested in stories i have
um an ending that presents the audience
with a sense of hope a sense of
betterment a sense that they can get
through anything the starling is that
story the starling is the story of this
couple who does goes through something
unfathomable and gets to the other side
and i just found that inspiring it's
interesting because when you made the
movie obviously you had no idea kobit
was coming but the timing of this
release with what a lot of people have
gone through i think you could have
never predicted this but i think you
know um maybe the timing is pretty good
timing is great because like the world
is going through a collective grieving
process right if we think about the last
two years
everyone you know everyone i know has
lost someone knows someone who's lost
someone dealt with um
death and sickness and illness people
have had covet people have
you know ever everything and also you
know loss of um our our privileges and
the ability to be with people to be able
to be with family it's like a big
collective
grieving collective sadness that the
world's experienced over the last two
years and
i think the timing of this movie
couldn't be better because the movie is
really about that the movie is really
about okay
there's grief bad bad things have
happened bad things will always happen
um i kind of baked into life but uh
goodness doesn't always happen and
laughter doesn't always happen and
happiness doesn't always happen and the
movie's about that the movie's about how
do you get through this grief
right with elegance
right with care with kindness um and
that's what these two that's what these
two do they show us kind of they show us
as the audience says there's a way out
and the way i was through and they kind
of push through and get through and work
on each other and work on their
relationship and they find the
proverbial light at the end of the
tunnel
i'm curious
so how does it work as a director when
you are filming like an emotional scene
for example i'm gonna use the hospital
scene in this where you have
chris who needs to you know he's gonna
break down you have melissa who's gonna
be crying i'm just curious how are you
actually directing something like that
knowing
that i mean i don't know how it works
but i would imagine the actor can't keep
on crying again and again and again
there's sort of like you know what i
mean like you're going to probably get a
few good takes
i'm just guessing i'm not a director but
i'm just curious if you could talk about
that uh i don't really believe in a lot
of takes i believe like if you cast um
the right actors and you have a script
you trust and have faith in
there's no reason to do 50 takes there's
no reason to do 10 takes like
after five takes i'm like really what's
what if after five takes something's
wrong for me right other people have a
different system and a different way of
working that's fine but after five takes
i'm like wondering what's wrong
something's not working the actors best
take i have always found like their
first thing like it's their raw gut
instinct on the material and they just
kind of do it and they're not really
aware of it they're not really aware of
themselves or it yet they just kind of
do it it kind of comes out and you're
like that's that's it and then i found
over the course of the years
that in take two three four and five
you're really trying to get back to what
they didn't take one so you're like okay
you know i've learned over the years you
know watch take one very very carefully
as you watch all takes very carefully
but pay attention to what what's great
about it because the odds are you're
going to want that again so it's like
it's just that kind of modulation so you
get a great so i don't spend a lot of
time um
beating the beating actors up or beating
material up it's like it's either
working or it's not if it's not working
gotta find a different solution
it's interesting because uh clint
eastwood is known for filming the
rehearsal and maybe he'll get one more
take and that's it and then obviously
you a fincher who might do let's just
say a few more um and it all works it's
just a question of you know um do you
film the rehearsal then
uh sometimes yeah sometimes i film
rehearsal um
i do that a lot with children with kids
with children i film the rehearsal
because they they're like not aware um
but a lot of times the actors don't like
to shoot rehearsal it just it just
depends on who the actor is there's no
there's no right or a wrong answer it's
kind of like it's really ultimately
whatever works whatever makes the actor
most comfortable whatever gets the best
performance out of them is the technique
you use at that given time at that given
point in the film
on that note i got to stop i'm just
going to say congrats on the film i hope
it's a huge hit for you thank you for
giving me your time thank you so much
take care